there are people in Hollywood code
script supervisors whose job is to make
sure that there aren't any silly or
stupid continuity mistakes in their
movie and often they totally fail so
don't worry if you've never picked up on
these cinematic goofs because here are
some big movie mistakes that everyone
failed to notice Terminator 3 plane
switch when John and Kathryn decide to
make an airborne getaway they head to a
blue and white Cessna parked in the
hangar as they enter the plane the
identifying numbers on the side of the
plane read n 3 0 3 5 C a subsequent shot
of the plane flying over the arid
landscape shows that the plane is now n
3 9 7 3 F finally when they land the
plane the number switches one more time
back to the original M 3 0 3 5 C dire
never days vanishing scar in this James
Bond adventure
Bond girl jinx gets into a saber fight
with Miranda Frost at one point during
the fight jinx takes a nasty slash to
her midsection splitting her shirt open
and leaving a bleeding shallow wound
later double-oh-seven and jinx are
reveling in the hoard of diamonds and He
pours a handful across her stomach which
is completely unblemished by any
scratches or wounds oops
Harry Potter and the magic shirt in
Harry Potter on the order of the Phoenix
Harry has a bad dream after an argument
with Sheamus and the Gryffindor common
room during that dream Harry is shown
thrashing around in a light blue crew
neck t-shirt when he wakes up he sits up
when it's wearing a dark blue button of
Henle shirts that Henley actually comes
from a later dream sequence in the film
when Harry is dreaming about Arthur
Weasley in the Department of mysteries
Rocky Horror Picture Show is vanishing
jewelry Eddie has the words love and
hate tattooed on his knuckles and Rocky
Horror Picture Show and his left hand
this accessorized with several rings
including an Iron Cross pinkie ring
eagle-eyed rocky horror fans may notice
that the ring disappears while Eddie
plays saxophone only to reappear later
with no explanation even the rings
aren't what they appear in Rocky Horror
Terminator twos magic windshield in a
pivotal scene at the t1000 commandeer as
a helicopter literally head-butting
through the windshield to gain entry and
take control this leaves a gaping hole
in the shattered glass but later in a
zoomed-out shot of the helicopter
pursuing Sarah Connor and the Terminator
on a highway the windshield is magically
fixed the magic helicopter gets even
crazier after it somehow explodes then
somehow immediately repairs itself and
that explodes again Lord of the wrists
merry and pippin are taken captive by
the ORAC I in the Lord of the Rings the
two towers but they managed to escape
withdrawing a middle-of-the-night raid
by the horse Lords of Rohan
the hobbits crawl away from the battle
hindered by their bound hands at one
point however Pippin is nearly trampled
by a horse and he rolls on his back and
flails has suddenly untied hands around
in fear after the danger of getting
stumped underfoot has passed he resumes
crawling away with his hands tied again
and he and Mary use a blade to cut
through their bonds gladiator tank
during one of the gladiators big fight
sequences three different chariots end
up flipping over pay close attention to
the third chariot as it lurches sideways
and crashes you can clearly see a tank
of some sort of compressed gas used in
the Sun just hanging out strapped to the
bottom of the chariot alien hoody fans
of the original alien may have spotted
one glaring continuity air above the
film's wardrobe when the crew is
exploring the bone ship Cain is shown
wearing a clothes fitted cloth hood
under his space helmet he's attacked by
a face hugger and when they cut his
helmet off the hood is nowhere to be
seen
maybe the alienator Wizard of Oz slipper
switch even the most famous props in
movie history were involved in an
onscreen screw-up yes Dorothy's ruby
slippers do the disappearing act during
a sequence when she and scarecrow get
attacked by an apple tree instead she's
wearing a pair of decidedly non magical
black and tan lace-up saddle shoes
there's no place like Payless thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're loved too
[Music]